good evening when all one
Rosemond looks through the camera loans
he sees
well beyond what you and I see he sees
not only an image a picture but also a
story in every scene a story which is a
miniscule aspect of the entire film the
two movies I made was all on straight
time and Tootsie couldn't be more
different
and so appropriately Owen saw them very
differently he was able to translate the
nuances of the tone and shading of each
story into literal nuances of tone and
shading and light and dark that you can
see right up there on the screen it's
this combination of insight and
versatility and craft that make Owen
royzman special the festival of his
films would not just be a showcase for
Owens remarkable talent it would be a
journey across genres as what's now
regarded as the contemporary style for
camerawork which was created by Owen and
his contemporaries he did it for gritty
realistic dramas he did it for glossy
mainstream comedies and he did it with
big and small budgets he did it for
intimate character pieces and for great
epics he did it for everything I'll give
you just one example of Owens integrity
as a craftsman and a person before we
started shooting Tootsie I had had a
number of makeup tests for almost a year
to get the transition to Dorothy
Michaels but I wasn't satisfied that and
I learned then that we all have a beard
shadow no matter how close you shave the
camera will see the shadow beneath the
skin and I didn't think it was being
concealed sufficiently
if you know the film you know how
important is that the makeup looks as
convincing as possible so that if you
were walking down the street and you saw
this gal you wouldn't stop and say who's
that guy in drag the director Sydney
[ __ ] assured me that the problem
would be fixed in color correction but
it still nagged at me so while we were
shooting
I asked Owen what he thought in front of
Sydney he said that he didn't think
color correction would take care of it
that only meant that we shut down
production which we did we went back to
the drawing board for over a week and
eventually we came up with a solution
that according to Owen
worked on camera but it took a lot of
courage for Owen to contradict a
director in front of the actor that's
not something you're really supposed to
do ever and it's a tribute to the
breadth of Owens great talent that he
was able to see both the problem and
envision a solution and the
cinematographer who knows as much about
makeup as about focal length and depth
of field is oscar-worthy in my book
congratulations on for sharing with us
this richly deserved honor and thank you
for sharing with us your remarkable gift
ladies and gentlemen this is for Owen
[Applause]